favoriser les déplacements de proximité
c'est la raison pour laquelle une
navette électrique vient d'arriver à
triel sur seine jusqu'au 26 janvier le
service est en phase d'expérimentation
pour valider les choix faits en
concertation avec les habitants
avec cette concertation n'a pu définir
certains arrêts donc des arrêts qui sont
stratégiques au niveau de la ville après
on a établi un planning donc minutes et
un chronométrage assez précis et
maintenant à pouvoir valider ce
chronométrage et aussi apporter
éventuellement des modifications c'est
le but d'une phase de test trois
circuits différents ont été choisis est
tous passés par le centre ville grâce à
la mobilité interne nous allons pouvoir
prendre les personnes lésées menons en
centre-ville et redynamiser le commerce
et donc développer l'attractivité du
centre-ville dans la navette il ya au
total 22 places 11 à 6 9 de boue et un
emplacement pmr elle a coûté un peu plus
de 250000 euros mais déjà subventionné à
hauteur de 30% et pour les usagers elle
sera gratuite
la modernité des moyens de transport
aujourd'hui c'est aussi d'offrir quelque
chose
socialement qui sont intéressants et
pour toutes les catégories de personnes
qui résident à triel et c'était aussi un
enjeu capital pour l'avenir de notre
mobilité
ces nouveaux modes de transport pourra
aussi être utilisé en dehors de ces
horaires habituels lors d'événements
organisés par la ville
nous allons à partir de la rentrée de
septembre 2021 offrir la possibilité aux
triellois de pouvoir lorsque le la crise
sanitaire le permettra bien entendu pour
l'événementiel pouvoir se déplacer plus
facilement dans un système de
géolocalisation a été mis en place les
triellois peuvent donc suivre une
navette en temps réel sur l'application
nba